It’s a pretty sweet gig that we’ve got...to
act as a tour guide through the microcosmos,
and we’ve been fortunate to be joined by
you fellow travelers, bringing all of your
insightful thoughts, and very funny quips
and also good questions in the comments section.
So for today, we wanted to turn it around
and let some of the most frequent questions
we’ve received guide this episode so we
can talk more about how things work behind
the scenes here, and how it impacts this
journey.
Many of you have asked how we find and care
for our microscopic friends.
Well, James, our collector of microbes and
master of microscopes, takes samples literally
from everywhere he can, but his favorite spot
is a park just next to his house.
Collecting these samples requires some high
tech equipment like...a selfie stick.
Which James bought and converted into a portable
sampling stick that lets him reach tough spots.
It’s lightweight.
It’s collapsable, what else do you need!
Once we have collected our specimens, we can’t
ignore them, we have to take care of them,
keep them alive and thriving.
For James, that means a few things: protecting
them from environmental factors like direct
sunlight or sudden changes in temperature,
while also providing them with a nutritious
setting that allows them to grow.
This of course looks different for different
microbes.
For algae, James adds a couple drops of liquid
plant fertilizer into the water and gives
them some natural sunlight.
But heterotrophs like ciliates and flagellates,
they need food, and James has a number of
different homemade solutions that provide
that sustinance.
From nearly the beginning of microbe hunting,
a favorite food has been a hay infusion, and
that is something that James uses as well.
It's basically just...boiled hay.
Other times, he might sprinkle some cooked
rice grains into the sample, or add drops
of milk.
It’s a whole menu designed to suit different
organisms, but no matter what they demand,
the goal is the same: to make sure we’re
taking care of our little pond buddies.
Now to the most frequent question of all,
our equipment.
When it comes time to get a closer look at
our cultures, we’ve used two different microscopes
to film the footage you’ve seen on this
channel.
The first one is a microscope that James cobbled
together from various parts for just under
$200, creating hundreds of hours of recorded
footage that we still use.
So this one is a microcosmos original.
You can’t buy it, there is only one, and
there is no brand name.
After we launched our channel, James got a
sponsorship from a microscope company—maybe
the most niche (and, we think, one of the
coolest) sponsorships you can get—and since
then, he’s used a Motic BA310 microscope
and a Fujifilm X-T3 camera.
With this microscope, we’ve been able to
expand on the kind of footage we can show
thanks to the different types of light we
can use, like these paramecia that we observed
under polarized light.
We’re very excited about all the different
forms of light you can use with this microscope
and what they reveal about the microcosmos,
and you will see more of that in future episodes.
Another common question...how do we prepare
and observe our samples...how do we actually
get a look at these organisms?
Well, the procedure is fairly similar each
time.
We first take a drop from our samples and
place that on a glass slide, and then we cover
that drop with another super-thin piece of
glass called a coverslip.
That creates an extremely thin film of water
between those two pieces of glass, and that
is what we observe when we make our videos.
Some of you have asked why we can see microbes
moving left, right, up, and down, but they
never seem to move towards or away from us.
Of course, microbes live in a three dimensional
universe, but our footage does not always
reflect that because of how microscopes work.
The high magnification objectives that we
use have a low depth of field, meaning the
area that is in focus is a very thin slice.
So we force the microcosmos into a two dimensional
space, this very thin area between the two
pieces of glass.
Now sometimes we actually make that area thicker
for larger organisms by putting some stuff
under the coverslip.
Maybe it’s some decaying plant matter or
some tiny grains of sand.
In those cases, however, it becomes easier
for those organisms to wander out of focus
Our microscope also shapes the way we observe
the color of these organisms, or often, what
seems to be the lack thereof.
We’ve been asked why so many of them are
transparent, and, well, transparency comes
down to two things.
First, how much light there is, and second
how much stuff there is blocking that light.
In the case of microscopic observation...there’s
a lot of light, and the bodies are tiny.
Some of these organisms just lack the pigments
that would make them colorful.
But for others, the light source in the microscope
is just too strong, overpowering their pigments
so they appear, to our eyes, transparent.
And you would be transparent too if you were
only a few microns thick.
Some of you also want to know whether we use
stains to create our footage.
Stains are a common laboratory and medical
technique that uses dyes to bind to different
parts of cells and thus help visualize their
components and processes.
While they are often beautiful and very informative,
stains can also be harmful to cells, potentially
even killing them so we have chosen to keep
the microorganisms un-stained.
There have also been questions about what
our magnification notes mean.
Those 100x’s and 200x’s you see up in
the corner.
Those numbers refer specifically to the magnification
created by the microscope, not how much larger
the image is as it appears on your screen,
relative to its actual size.
Now that is a subtle difference, but subtle
differences can be very important.
After all, some of you are watching this on
your phones, others are watching on a computer
screen, others might be watching on a big
70” flat screen on your wall and if you
are, that’s awesome.
Thank you.
We, however, do not know what size device
you’re watching this on, but you’re seeing
the same 100x in the corner because that describes
the optics of the microscope, not the size
of the screen you’re using to watch YouTube
videos.
To fix this, we’ve gotten a lot of comments
asking us to use a scale bar instead of the
magnification, and we’ve been thinking about
non-intrusive ways of implementing that.
And finally, we’ve had questions about how
real-time our footage is.
We always make sure to note whether the footage
we’re showing has been sped up.
Sometimes the microbes we show you are super
chill and relaxed, and sometimes, they are
very much not chill, moving faster than many
of us might expect.
We’re asked sometimes whether any particular
piece of footage has been sped up, and rest
assured that unless we’ve noted it, that
very active microbe is just very active.
I mean, calm down friend.
You can take a breather.
And so can all of us every once in a while.
Thank you so much for all of your questions
and all your comments over these months.
We hope that by answering them, you find new
things to ponder and ask us about the micrococosmos.
A question that doesn’t pose new questions
is no question at all.
And if, say, you are wondering whether this
channel reminds us of the cell stage in the
game Spore…the answer is of course yes,
yes it very much does.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
We also just recently launched our very first piece of microcosmos merch!
I'm wearing it right now, though you cannot see that,
because there are no cameras on me,
but I promise I am.
It's a Stentor Coeruleus pin,
and the image of the Stentor on the pin is roughly 40x the size of what a real-world Stentor coerules is,
So when people see it, you can tell them that.
And you can own this little piece
of the microcosmos, there's a link, in the description.
Thank you so much to all of our patrons on
Patreon who make it possible for us to do
this weird thing that we love doing
And if you want to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James, you can check out Jam
and Germs on Instagram.
And, of course, if you want to subscribe to
Journey to the Microcosmos, I bet you can
figure out how to do that.